three major MCU characters could be
brought back to life in phase four and
in Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness what's up everyone it's Warren
and yes I did say three MCU characters
could be brought back to life one of
which is already confirmed the other two
are rumored but could very easily be
done and they make a lot of sense so
I'll break down the support and also
talk about how it ties into the comics
there's also been a report that we could
be getting a new Iron Man in the MCU as
well I'm still doing my xbox one and ps4
giveaway so be sure to subscribe a like
and comment on the video to enter so
three characters that could be making a
return to the MC one of which everybody
has been waiting for for a pretty long
time now and that is quick silver the
other two are the ancient one and of
course a vision now Quicksilver being
killed and then revived as something
that comes directly from the comics in
the House of M and son of M series and
based off of everything that we know
about Doctor Strange in the multiverse
of madness it does seem like the MCU is
going kind of towards a house of M
situation now we know that vision is
going to be revived in the wand of
vision series you can't really have a 1
a vision series without vision so of
course it's already confirmed but we do
know that the Scarlet Witch and possibly
vision is going to play a major part in
the multiverse of madness tilda swinton
is also rumored to be making a return in
the film as well which makes perfect
sense she returned for avengers endgame
so she is clearly open to playing the
character again and the ancient one was
a major character of the first Doctor
Strange film so it would make sense that
she would be in the second one now as
far as how she could return there are
really a couple of ways that this could
happen one is that it could be an
ancient one from a different universe
this is the multiverse of madness so
Doctor Strange is going to be dealing
with a bunch of different universes in
this film and it's possible that she
could simply come over from a different
dimension this is a relatively easy way
to bring her back and since the ancient
one is all-knowing it would pretty much
be the same character but the other way
has to do with the same way that
Quicksilver could be making a return and
has a lot to do with the Scarlet Witch
so just to give a tiny bit of background
information about the House of M comic
series for those of you who don't know
it's a limited 8th book series that came
out in 2005 in which the Scarlet Witch
basically loses her mind
invision have two sons but unfortunately
they both died this causes her to have a
mental breakdown and she alters the
reality that everybody lives in during
this reality some characters are brought
back to life like Hawkeye but as it
turns out it was really her brother
Quicksilver that had a lot to do with
her altering reality and this causes
their father who in this run is magneto
to get extremely mad and he ends up
killing Quicksilver but the Scarlet
Witch soon brings him back to life
so this premise right here is probably
what we're going to be dealing with in
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness we are not really 100% sure of
what is going to cause the multiverse to
go into madness it could simply just be
the effects of the aftermath of avengers
endgame creating multiple timelines and
alternate realities or it could kind of
be just like the House of M we know that
the one division series is casting two
babies that means that Wanda and visions
sons are going to be in the series Wanda
and vision are going to have their two
sons Wiccan and speed now killing two
children doesn't really seem like the
route that Disney would go down but that
doesn't mean that something couldn't
happen to them that would end up making
the Scarlet Witch lose her mind also not
to mention that there has been a plot
leak for Doctor Strange where it says
only one of her children show up and
that is Wiccan so as far as what
happened to speed we are not sure but
either way it seems like the Scarlet
Witch is going to create some type of
alternate reality and in this alternate
reality she could bring back Quicksilver
now we know that Aaron taylor-johnson
signed a multimedia contract when he
signed up to play Quicksilver for age of
Ultron however he was killed during the
movie kind of hard to do more than one
movie when you're dead unless you get
revived somehow and if only you had a
sister who was a sorceress that was
strong enough to do that oh wait he does
you didn't see that's coming so this is
a possible way that Quicksilver could be
making his return his sister could
create an alternate reality type of
thing a reality in which he is still
alive which seems like the direction
that everything is going so we know that
vision is going to be returning but it
seems like we could be seeing the return
of the ancient one and Quicksilver in
phase 4 in the multiverse of madness now
I also mentioned a new Iron Man that
could be coming to the MCU and this is
in no way a reservoir
of Tony Stark rather it is going to be a
new Iron Man figure it's actually going
to be Iron Heart who is RiRi Williams in
the comics now of course this is not
confirmed yet but according to a report
from MCU cosmic according to his source
that he has said has never been wrong an
iron heart Disney Plus series is in
early development at Marvel Studios one
of the biggest questions of the MC right
now is who is going to be the next Iron
Man a lot of people are looking at
Spider Man slash Peter Parker but he's
spider-man when everybody asks if
spider-man is going to take the place of
Iron Man they don't mean that literally
they just mean that in terms of
leadership but there's a vacancy for an
actual Iron Man right now and it seems
like Marvel may be going to Disney Plus
wear out and introduce Iron Heart so not
only could we see three MCU characters
come back to life but we could also be
getting a new Iron Man in the MCU as
well I would personally love to see
Quicksilver make a return to the MCU but
let me know what you think in the
comments down below if you love Marvel
content and don't forget to subscribe to
my channel I post Marvel content daily
and also don't forget to like the video
and comment below so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof